The scale on a map is 7
centimeters for every 10
kilometers, or 7 centimeters
for 10 kilometers.
If the distance
between two cities
is 60 kilometers-- so
that's the actual distance--
how far apart in centimeters
are the two cities on the map?
Well, they give us the scale.
For every 10 kilometers
in the real world,
the map is going to
show 7 centimeters.
Or another way to
think about it is
if you see 7 centimeters
on the map, that represents
10 kilometers in the real world.
Now, they're saying that the
distance between two cities
is 60 kilometers.
So it's essentially 6 times
10 kilometers, so times 6.
So if you have to 6 times
10 kilometers on the map,
you're going to have 6 times
7 centimeters, so times 6.
And 6 times 7 centimeters
gets you to 42 centimeters.
So how far apart in centimeters
are the two cities on the map?
Well, 42 centimeters.